yeah so Ralph Sampson on joining us on
behalf of AT&T the official corporate
champion of NC double-a Ralph one of the
great college players of all time of
course had his run here with the Houston
Rockets it's good to see you
oh good to be here you look good you
look I'm trying to stay in fit shape
somehow do you play basketball anymore
no but do you get to the point where
it's a job like you you just it like I
enjoy shooting basketball but did you
get to a point where you just don't want
you don't want any part of it you don't
like doing it or the outlet now the the
mindset if you can't play like you used
to play so the mind will say what I was
like my mind right there just shooting
those baskets like I'm in Houston I can
play let's go play let's go play tennis
court basket I can get a couple rebounds
like a couple shots but then the knees
say yeah different so you're like if I
can't do it I met with just let it go I
like to teach of the kids and stuff like
that but first plan I didn't leave alone
cuz then people challenge you and then
you got to go and say that's likes them
up tighter and let's get with it and
then next day you feel really bad
because you saw how what was the
recruiting process like when you're
coming out of high school
oh my goodness first I had a great high
school coach that you know thousands of
schools calling every day he put
together a system if you called if you
did these other thing we had the raffle
rules basically if you called a certain
time we didn't you know we actually off
the list so we had to find the city of
Harrisonburg Virginia had fun I mean we
had two or three thousand people that
some games every every night were you
seven four years no no I was six seven
in the ninth grade and I played on the
JV team and played on varsity at the end
of the end of that year the next year I
was white 610 grew three or four inches
every year I was step one when I left
high school and then I grew to 74 in
college if you could have changed it to
be 6-4 instead of 74 I wouldn't change
it for the world
no no I like being seven four really
love it what are the benefits now well
besides you know ducking under doorways
and
ya know airplane seats too small and
stuff like that getting a car in the car
you know you move your car back you move
your tractor back on your car and
insurance State UK movie called the
airbag and all the concepts that came
with seat back so you got those illegal
things you do stories fun but now I just
enjoy tell people you can't hide 74 you
can hide 64 but you can't hide 7 4 so
you better be prepared to go out and no
matter no no if they know you play or
not they say you must have played
basketball how's the weather up there
really and did you ever play the NBA so
and then some people recognize you from
a face at all you are okay great but you
don't look like that because you should
be older so they get all kind of stories
how famous were you in college how
famous oh I just I'm just Ralph I don't
know how that was there was a buildup I
mean you were a household name you know
Patrick Ewing and you the rivalry there
did you did you have fun with it
I loved it I mean I had great people
around me I mean I had a great high
school coach in Roger Berg II had a
great colors coach in Terry Holland and
I saw my s ID last night and Doug Elgin
and they had a great set and I said they
had a room that's ideal fit maybe 500
square feet and the next year we had a
whole building and so they took very
good care of me at Virginia and I had a
good time with those people so it's uh I
had fun every day he's Ralph Sampson
joining us here on program in Houston
what's the one memory what comes to mind
if I say Houston and your NBA career Wow
a couple things one being drafted by
Houston and knowing I was coming to the
city
- man right I was number one riding
McCray was number three great friend of
mine so I'm the other day flying on Lear
Jets here to the summit which is now
Joel Osteen's church and having
thousands of people there welcomed us to
the city was amazing so still love this
place when I got off the plane on where
they're like I should come back here and
live this is a great city for me and I
just love the heat and the humidity
which most people don't like well you
got to do it on here well you know I
came from a Hall of Fame event so they
just announced in their class so you're
not sweating no yeah oh you will not yet
no it's not hot enough sweat yeah
Houston's not here but yeah but the
expectation level on a big man
it's we always expect more from Kareem
I mean it doesn't matter everybody it's
almost it's like you can't live up to
the expectations because you're a
certain height yeah you ran into that
too why any kid that's larger than most
kids you you got to play basketball or
you should play basketball if you did
that's a waste of height so you hear all
kinds of stories then if you play the
expectations are enormous because of the
giants that played before I'm in a cream
seven to thirty seven thousand points
greatest skyhook greatest shot in
basketball how can you live up to those
expectations that somebody already laid
out so if you don't have that standard
then guess what it's not that big and
that's the only I mean you got a point
guard standards Oscar Roberts and those
guys as well but if you were tall you
got to play basketball and that's what
this world is about but we set our own
expectations I didn't expect anything
more out of myself than what I wanted
not a worry about anybody else what they
expected I expected the best out of
myself every day you played against
Jordan in the ACC right yeah no so you
saw him his freshman year yes freshman
year and sophomore year okay what did
you if I would have said to you at the
time you know that that guy's gonna
probably be recognized the greatest
player of all time what would you said
um he was good I mean I mean the the
only thing that the thing said well only
one who ever helped Michael Jordan ah
was Nesmith and so he couldn't score
that many points so I recall you played
I knew he was pretty good when we played
down there we get ready run the game and
he coming up to court and he steals the
ball from one of our point guards and
goes down and dunks it and I mean the
defensive ability at that point time was
huge I think he more pleased he played
better defense in college and learned
the defensive fighting modes in college
and then the outfit of stuff just
blossom in the NBA so you knew something
was special at that point time but you
to know how much best player you ever
played against um you know I gotta go
with the big guys I think the best
player ever is Bill Russell with the
utmost respect 11 rings if you going on
championships but creme has got to be
one of the best every iconic player is
underrated Ralph well I think he's
underrated maybe underappreciated under
yeah you know so and why can't we teach
somebody the skyhook well you know it
cream if you go back history London sky
hook because they took the dunk out of
the basketball because it got to him and
you know you too big no bells that big
you can't dunk the ball so he had to
learn how to put it up their way so
wooden and that whole crews okay
finalists I mean I think it just
developed over time and then he
perfected it and he can try to teach
somebody but it's not gonna work it's
like it's like down here in Houston do
Kim Olajuwon trying to teach the dream
shake the Dwight Howard it doesn't work
it doesn't work
Hakeem was one of the best ever so
everybody got their own little way to
play and everybody develop their own
game why can't big men shoot free-throws
haha what goes back even the world
chamber right
you shoot free-throws and one year he
what he saw my shoot a better percentage
and he did I was over the whole thing
was shocked that's getting inducted
today and you know his hands are so big
and the ball is so small it's so
powerful it's a different to directly to
the basket so it's not an arch like the
McDonald's arch is more of a straight
line shot you got to have touch when
some big guys just don't have that touch
and it's hard to show you had touch but
you only shot 67 percent from line well
I shoulda shot better but you had touch
though I had a little touch but you know
it was out of softer touch maybe and
some guys that are this size but it's
getting a different line to your basket
and sometimes it just doesn't you know
it doesn't work you know how many threes
you had in your career right not enough
if I play today I had a lot more would
you be a three-point absolutely well
yeah but I don't want my seven four guy
on the perimeter I play you would you be
like porzingis you mentioned earlier I
play with my new bow and go to stay with
Don Nelson manukan shoot this ring who
shoots is three so you imagine I'm 74
he's seven seven lead out oh my god I
looked up to and so he was good but we
can shoot it three at that point time so
I wish I probably shot I mean the game
was different today because it a
pick-and-roll and then there's spray the
defense so you have to learn how to
shoot a three and they say my game was
maybe before it's time so I was shot
more I grow more uh you had you made ten
threes how's it yes
not many yeah I mean that's just Steph
Curry a great night a great a great
turnout at Sands Resort and I know
you're representing AT&T
yes I don't know if you need to have a
plug there or anything to with that
other than AT&T is good we've
all in doing some stuff today this
afternoon as well so ATT what a company
got to be a part of all this especially
when your show I watch you all the time
and just having fun in Houston at the
Final Four
it's great to see you around it is um
and I we played I think the highlight of
you with that turnaround jumper when you
beat the Lakers oh yeah yeah yeah how
much luck was involved in that shot
there well I'll tell people so we came
out of a very grueling seven-game series
with the Denver Nuggets and and manda
came actually has fouled out and I've
bench had Craig Ehlo
Graham Bell waiters Jim Petersen and
some guys riding McRae that won the game
for us we're going to Los Angeles we
lose the first game like really bad and
then we win the next three and I tell
magic all the time I said you know it's
like Ralph you got us on that shot it
wasn't a shot we do beat you anyway cuz
we come to music you gonna lose em we
cuz we're coming home but riding McRae
said there wasn't a shot it was this
pass so I give all the credit right
McRae and I was in Boston when you're
facing the Celtics with the whole Gerry
see sting thing with the fight and no me
not that crowd was the the garden was
pretty tough on your own it was tough
but I went back home and got my two
weightlifting coach that were with me
when they both were 300 pounds one guy
named John gam we actually the way
straight coach for the Buffalo Bills now
so what a man and they went with me
because the hallways that don't come to
Boston we gonna kill you we gonna do is
that desperate he got a few threats but
we played anyway so with all right did
you ever talk to Gerry see sting about
that it's funny I was coaching in
Phoenix a couple years ago and we never
really talked about that incident but
they were I was a play development coach
and they had gotten rid of all the
coaches but me at that point in time
insisting was one of the new coaches
coming in I said we can't really have
y'all gettin animosity between each
other thirty years ago so whatever's
that way if he throws another elbow I
will take him out
haha that's the way to go hey great to
see you thank you thank you for showing
bite the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience